[Music]
you posted some pictures of you and and
and you seemed to post photos of you
with Johnny Knoxville recently and I
thought it's funny because I don't
equate you with hanging out with Johnny
Knoxville me and the Knox white there I
don't know
no so I did this charity event he was
there is great charity in Kansas City
called big slick raised lots of money
for this Children's Hospital but we're
on stage and they're auctioning things
off and Johnny started stealing
everyone's cell phones so we all just
had our cell phone next to us and we're
like involved in the auction and he
would just grab it and he was doing this
to everyone he grabbed my phone but I'd
realized that he goes hey Angela who's
Warren I'm like this is my ex-husband
why why and I grabbed the phone and he
texted my ex-husband so we need to talk
I'm pregnant this is going to change the
alimony I am not pregnant that was
Johnny Knoxville and then I was like I
was taking a picture of you to prove
that you're here doing this craziness
and then he started attacking me with a
sharpie yeah I think we have a picture
of this he he attacks your legs with a
sharpie why did he do that look at his
face he had the mustache on his face
that were he made weird al' drawn him
and he's so happy look how happy he is
right cuz he attacked me so what he just
drew a lot of lying little life I was
like talking this way I might have had a
cocktail I'm talking this way I'm not
paying too much attention and he grabbed
a sharpie and just went think I think I
did get a get it all over and then he
goes oh I wanted to look like you have a
hairy bush
[Music]
[Applause]
no you can't say it yeah yeah I'm sorry
that's fine I'm not my nurse at Boehner
and I said Bush you were backstage and
you ye bow of Carl Reiner
I knew that Boehner I'm all over it we
have a clip here
[Music]
if he's still back there he's headed
back I'm sure he's headed this way fast
housewives swerve Orlando the hotwives
of orlando this is sort of you guys
parroting the all the housewives shows
you get to play it's a sort of a dream
come true for you because you get to
play oh we've always wanted which is a
weather girl I am I know it's like I'm
just like Meryl Streep right I want to
play like a crappy weather girl or I
want to be the sassy girl in the morgue
you know that's like got a cigarette and
it's eating a tuna fish sandwich and
cutting something anyway but no I went
I've always want to play a really bad
weather girl who's like it's snow in
that square there yeah and I got to do
it no it's not much fun and I they also
brought me a box of boobs a little like
things oh those little cutlery I liked
cutlet you know and then we just kept
trying different sizes I feel like the
first day of filming my boobs I think
Jeb boobs changing sides
hilarious we have a clip here of you
this is your character from from the
hotwives of orlando doing the weather
yeah let's take a look okay being a
weather girl is my dream job and since
God controls the weather it's like I get
to be a personal spokesperson watch TV
there's a big storm front headed for New
Orleans I guess you didn't learn your
lesson last time about God's wrath about
your debauchery
sorry homosexuals a drought you hookers
alright you're not Lando as beautiful as
always thank you God Yahweh Father Son
and Holy Ghost back in Egypt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you